Новини дня, програма «heute» з Мітрієм Сіріним.
Усім прекрасного суботнього вечора,
Катя Штрезо із щоденною порцією новин спорту.
Про найважливіші події, спеціально відібрані для вас,
у найближчі 20 хвилин поговоримо про наступне.
Один загиблий, безліч поранених і величезні збитки -
грози вирують у деяких регіонах Німеччини.
торнадо проходять через Північний Рейн-Вестфалію.
Тяжкі атаки на сході -
після взяття Маріуполя Росія посилює наступ
на ﻿Донбасі.
З нетерпінням чекаємо на фінал Кубка -
«Фрайбурґ» і «Лейпциґ» сподіваються на перший
титул в історії своїх клубів.
Незвичайно високі травневі температури та
висока вологість,
що потім зустрілися із повітряними масами майже
на 20 градусів холоднішими -
такими були інґредієнти штормів,
які вирували вчора над значною частиною
Німеччини.
Особливо сильно постраждав Північний Рейн-Вестфалія.
За даними Німецької метеорологічної служби, там
було щонайменше три торнадо.
У Лютмарсені - район Хекстера, у Падерборні
та в Ліппштадті.
За оцінками поліції, збитки досягають мільйонів.
Щонайменше 43 особи дістали поранень, 13 із них -
тяжкі.
Про цей страшний шторм розповідають Дорте Фербер
і Аріана Ґюдель.
Наступного дня у Падерборні.
Дахи зірвані, дерева повалені,
люди ще досі шоковані.
Двері його кухні, просто вибиті.
Він ледве встиг упасти на землю.
Уся кухня завалена черепицею.
Якби я був тут, я загинув би.
Великі дерева лежать посеред вулиці,
я визирнув у вікно - вітер ламав їх як сірники,
справді стихійна сила,
від цього холодок по спині пробігає.
300 метрів завширшки, 5 кілометрів завдовжки,
швидкість вітру 150 кілометрів на годину -
так торнадо зруйнував учора центр міста
Падерборн.
Гілки, паркани, черепиця – все літає у повітрі.
Сьогоднішня оцінка мера.
Сотні співробітників служб з надзвичайної ситуації,
43 поранених,
у тому числі жінка, яка досі бореться за своє життя.
Падерборн в розпачі, Падерборн шокований
і Падерборн більш ніж глибоко вражений.
Шпиль церкви просто зірвало -
торнадо промайнув і над Ліппштадтом.
Стихійна сила, неймовірна та нова за своїм масштабом.
Через півгодини все закінчилося,
і всі дерева, особливо на узбіччях,
впали на дороги, це була неймовірна руйнація,
якої ми ще не бачили.
Масштаби цих руйнувань поки що не піддаються
кількісній оцінці.
У другій половині дня уряд землі
Північний Рейн-Вестфалія
отримує першу фотографію з місця події.
Це лихо ще раз показує,
що нам доведеться готуватися до таких
екстремальних погодних явищ дедалі частіше.
Що ми повинні бути підготовлені для них,
і, звичайно, це також показує важливість захисту клімату.
Вчора три торнадо пронеслися Східною Вестфалією
і були для багатьох неочікуваними, попри
наполегливі попередження.
Залишилися одні уламки –
усунення цієї шкоди займе багато часу.
Аріана Ґюдель для нас у Падерборні:
Яка ситуація через день після мегабуревію в
регіоні?
Наступного дня настає день прозріння.
Багато хто, мабуть, тільки сьогодні усвідомив,
з якою силою природи вони зіткнулися вчора.
Багато хто говорив, що і через день їх трясе.
Вони повідомили, як швидко з'явився торнадо
і як він пішов.
Багато хто каже, що їм пощастило,
бо принаймні не було смертельних випадків.
У Падерборні можна побачити шлях, яким рухався
торнадо.
Майже кожний будинок на цій вулиці постраждав.
З дахів зникла черепиця,
шибки розбиті,
у деяких будинках усі вікна
вибиті з рам усередину.
Зі стін відпадає штукатурка.
Все вже не як раніше.
Через кілька вулиць звідси люди, як завжди,
проводили суботній день у саду.
Можна знову побачити, чому торнадо вирує,
обмежуючись кількома вулицями.
Чоловік показав нам, як гілка дерева
пронизала наскрізь стіну
на четвертому поверсі його будинку.
Після мене звідси виїжджає ще одна сім'я,
дах повністю знесло.
Багато тих, з ким ми розмовляли, сьогодні вражені тим,
що їм довелося пережити щось подібне.
Дуже дякую, Аріана Ґюдель.
Буревії також завдали великої шкоди в інших регіонах.
У Вестервальді чоловік загинув від удару струмом
у затопленому підвалі.
Біля озера Гросер Бромбахзеє завалився дерев'яний
будинок.
14 людей, які шукали там захист, отримали
поранення.
Одну дитину довелося доставити до лікарні на
гелікоптері.
Загалом пожежну бригаду у Франконії викликали
понад 400 разів.
У Верхній Лужиці літаючі об'єкти
спричинили кілька інцидентів протягом ночі.
У Шмеквіці 200-річне дерево впало на будинок.
На щастя, ніхто не постраждав.
Після падіння Маріуполя на сході України
продовжуються запеклі бої.
З Луганської та Донецької областей надходять
повідомлення про тяжкі бої.
Українці побоюються, що, продовжуючи наступ,
Росія може досягти успіху
у створенні сухопутного мосту до Криму.
Ми поговоримо у прямому ефірі з
нашим репортером,
який знаходиться у стратегічно дуже важливому
портовому місті Одеса,
а перед цим репортаж Фолькера Дучека.
Українські розвідувальні війська в дорозі
біля лінії фронту на Луганщині.
Тут, на самому сході України, російська армія
втратила багато танків та солдатів
за останні кілька тижнів.
Але після падіння Маріуполя
Москва хоче продовжити наступ.
Останніми днями російські обстріли різко посилилися.
Українська армія наразі контролює лише два міста
в Луганській області -
Сєвєродонецьк та Лисичанськ.
І з кожним днем ​​дедалі більше мешканців
залишають місто.
Наприклад, Дмитро Мозур.
32-річний чоловік хоче виїхати з Лисичанська.
Його дружина загинула під час мінометного
обстрілу.
Він стоїть на автобусній зупинці зі своїми дітьми.
Все, про що я можу думати, - як вивезти звідси моїх
доньок,
і ми зможемо повернути наше життя в нормальне русло.
Якщо Донецький та Луганський райони будуть під
контролем росіян,
буде досягнута одна з основних цілей Кремля:
суцільний сухопутний коридор до
окупованого Криму.
Після здачі в полон українських солдатів
із заводу Азовсталь
Маріуполь більше не є символом надії та стійкості
проти російського агресора.
Місто майже повністю знищене.
Від колишніх 430 тисяч жителів залишилася лише
невелика частина.
Мало хто досі має цілу квартиру або дах над
головою.
У нашому будинку досі живуть лише чотири
мешканці,
четверо ось у тому будинку та ще три сім'ї поряд
з ним.
Харків, місто з населенням понад мільйон людей
на півночі країни,
все ще перебуває у стані блокади.
Населення відвоювало частину міста.
Але це вимагає багато жертв.
Скільки їх загинуло тут і у всій країні,
звичайно, стане відомо лише після війни.
Москва заявляє, що атакувала місто Малин,
розташоване на північний захід від Києва.
З моря було знищено великий вантаж боєприпасів
та обладнання
із США та Європи.
Наш колега Йоханнес Хано
проїхав автомобілем з Києва до Одеси.
Вітаю, Йоханнесе, яка ситуація в Одеській області
і на що там очікують?
Ситуація тут, в Одесі, дуже дивна.
Вуличні кафе відкриті, люди ходять у бари та паби.
З іншого боку, військові вкрай напружені та нервують.
У місті скрізь барикади
напевно розраховують на можливість вуличних боїв.
Нам не дозволяють нічого з цього показувати,
бояться, що це може послугувати російським
цілям.
Тут не вистачає туристів,
які зазвичай заповнюють місто в цю пору року,
бо немає бензину і сюди неможливо дістатися.
Нам довелося привезти із собою каністри з
бензином.
Крім того, існує проблема, що всі пляжі заміновані.
Україна побоюється нападу росіян.
І вважає, що російські війська можуть піти на
Одесу,
щоб відрізати Україну від моря.
Особливо під час війни людина намагається
зміцнювати союзи.
Президент США Байден прагне зближення не
тільки з партнерами по НАТО та ЄС,
але і зі стратегічними союзниками, такими як
Південна Корея,
щоб протистояти Китаю.
Саме тому Джо Байден вирушив до Сеула, щоб
зустрітися з новим президентом.
Ульф Реллер пояснює, як зупинити вплив Китаю
і як впоратися з небезпечним сусідом -
Північною Кореєю.
Кожна фотографія, кожна поява покликані
слугувати посланнями.
Байден вшановує пам'ять полеглих солдатів
Корейської війни.
На той час США разом із південнокорейськими
військами воювали проти Китаю.
Китай і сьогодні залишається найбільшим
суперником у регіоні.
Щоб стримати його силу,
новий Президент Південної Кореї прагне
зближення зі США.
США охоче беруть на себе місію
забезпечення миру та безпеки у світі.
Наші стосунки мають вирішальне значення для
миру та добробуту в регіоні.
Однак обидва президенти впевнені, що
наразі цей мир у небезпеці.
Тому вони прагнуть інтенсифікувати
військові навчання.
За словами президентів,
йдеться про захист свободи.
Ми з вами є свідками
переломного моменту у світовій історії.
Боротьби, що точиться між демократією та автократією.
До речі, про автократію:
на зустрічі неодноразово згадувалося ім'я
північнокорейського диктатора Кім Чен Ина.
Спалах коронавірусу суттєво послабив країну.
Але це не завадить Кім Чен Ину
продовжувати ракетні випробування
та розширювати програму ядерного озброєння.
Це становить найбільшу небезпеку для регіону.
Незважаючи на це, обидва лідери
висловили готовність до переговорів
з Північною Кореєю.
Двері до зали переговорів відчинені,
якщо Північна Корея справді
вирішить відмовитися від ядерної програми.
Сполучені Штати Америки продовжують
зближення зі своїми партнерами
не лише в Європі, а й в Азії.
Питання абортів
розділило американське суспільство.
Відколи стало відомо, що Верховний суд
планує скасувати право на аборт,
дедалі більше «червоних» штатів
засвідчили свою підтримку нового закону.
Рішення підтримує також і католицька церква,
яка останнім часом все частіше
з'являється в новинах.
Детальніше розповість Бенджамін Даніель.
Вона одна з найвпливовіших постатей в
американській політиці.
Проте від сьогодні вона більше не зможе
причаститися в рідній єпархії.
Так вирішив архієпископ Сан-Франциско.
Причина: Ненсі Пелосі підтримує право на аборти.
Це ще один приклад того, наскільки
гостро постало питання абортів у США.
У четвер, коли в штаті Оклахома було ухвалено
закон, який передбачає
кримінальну відповідальність за аборти,
країною прокотилася хвиля протестів.
Життя нової людини починається з моменту зачаття,
і ми будемо захищати це життя тут, в Оклахомі.
Інші штати можуть мати відмінну точку зору
в цьому питанні, але ми - за життя.
Імовірно, губернатор вже зовсім скоро схвалить
цей законопроєкт.
Коли закон набуде чинності, перервати вагітність
можна буде лише в тих випадках,
коли існує реальна загроза для життя матері
або якщо запліднення відбулося в результаті
інцесту або зґвалтування,
про яке попередньо було повідомлено поліцію.
Такі положення є несумісними з
федеральним законом про аборти,
адже Верховний Суд ще не скасував право на аборти.
Тому демократи хочуть вжити
відповідних заходів та зупинити республіканців.
Цей закон стане прямим порушенням основного
права - права на самовизначення,
права жити і любити без державного втручання.
Близько 60 відсотків американців виступають за
ліберальне регулювання права на аборт.
Проте це не заважає консервативній меншості
щосили намагатися протиставити
свої цінності волі більшості на всіх рівнях.
Тема продовжує розділяти американське суспільство
на два табори.
У рік виборів до Конгресу знову
відбувається поляризація суспільства,
що не може не тішити популістів.
В Австралії відбулися вибори.
За попередніми підрахунками, відомо,
що влада в країні зміниться!
Майже через 10 років
до влади повернуться соціал-демократи
на чолі з Ентоні Албанезе.
Головним пунктом політичної програми
соціал-демократів є зміна клімату,
що, імовірно, і забезпечило 59-річному Албанезе
безпрецедентну підтримку молоді на виборах.
Чинний прем'єр-міністр Австралії Скотт Моррісон,
лідер Ліберальної партії,
вже офіційно визнав свою поразку.
Проте, попри кліматичним обіцянкам,
навіть при новому уряді Австралія, певно,
залишиться найбільшим у світі експортером вугілля.
Всупереч шкоді для довкілля,
вугілля є ресурсом значного капіталу
та великої кількості робочих місць, до того ж
має неабиякий попит
у зв'язку з останніми подіями в Україні.
Далі - Норман Оденталь.
Австралія газує - як в прямому,
так і в переносному сенсі.
Видобуток вугілля відбувається не так швидко,
як цього хотілося б.
Чорний скарб Австралії має попит
у найрізноманітніших куточках Земної кулі -
від Китаю до Індії.
Кількість споживачів постійно зростає.
Це гарантує поповнення скарбниці австралійського
вугільного сектору.
Частина суспільства вітає таке джерело прибутку.
Я схильний вважати, що зважаючи на
актуальні події в Європі,
багатьом країнам варто переглянути
курс енергетичної політики.
З впевненістю можу сказати, що наше вугілля
стане чудовою енергетичною альтернативою.
Країни, які відмовляються від російських
енергоносіїв, потребують нових постачальників.
Вугільна промисловість Австралії готова
прийти на допомогу в енергетичній кризі.
Так, у сільському шинку на зміну страху перед
майбутнім прийшла впевненість у завтрашньому дні.
Запаси вугілля не вичерпались.
Через війну в Україні попит на вугілля
суттєво збільшився.
Певний час ситуація в Європі
лишатиметься нестабільною.
Наше вугілля необхідне для уникнення
енергетичної кризи,
до того ж, ми пропонуємо вугілля найкращої якості.
Від вугілля залежить багато речей.
Зокрема, робочі місця для шахтарів,
постачальників та інших людей, це цілий ланцюг.
І як тут відмовитися від видобутку вугілля?
Довгий час видобуток вугілля вважався неприйнятним
через негативний вплив на зміну клімату,
наслідки якої добре відчутні в Австралії
у найрізноманітніших проявах:
повені, лісові пожежі, екстремальна засуха.
Перспектива остаточної відмови від вугілля
далека, як ніколи.
На світовому ринку ціни на вугілля
зростають шаленими темпами.
Австралія – найбільший експортер вугілля у світі.
Коли вугільний бізнес процвітає,
аргументи екозахисників здаються
не такими вже й переконливими. Вугілля гріє
не лише оселі, а й державну скарбницю.
А зараз я передаю слово Каті Стрезо.
Як то кажуть: Берлін, Берлін, ми їдемо в Берлін!
Можливо, але спершу ми маємо завершити ефір.
Пісні фанатів справді лунатимуть в Берліні,
адже сьогодні ввечері на Олімпійському стадіоні
відбудеться фінал Кубку НФФ.
«Фрайбурґ» зустрінеться з «РБ Лейпциґ».
Переповнені трибуни вже чекають на видовищну гру.
Впевнена, що такою вона й буде.
Ані «Фрайбурґ», ані «РБ Лейпциґ» ніколи
не перемагали в Кубку Німеччини.
Обидві команди мають чудових нападників,
здатних забивати видовищні голи.
Як от, Еміль Форсберґ у «РБ Лейпциґ» або
Нільс Петерсен у «Фрайбурзі».
Тож фінал обіцяє бути по-справжньому запеклим.
Ми мріємо нарешті підійняти до неба омріяний кубок!
Ми йшли до цього роками, тож тепер,
коли ми отримали такий шанс,
ми просто не можемо його проґавити.
Позаду довгий шлях.
Ми хочемо, щоб усі наші зусилля нарешті
увінчалися успіхом, мріємо про чемпіонський титул.
Крістофер Нкунку з «РБ Лейпциґ»
«славиться» своїми фолами,
що не завадило йому стати кращим гравцем сезону.
За останні три роки саксонці програли
в двох фінальних матчах.
Тож чергова поразка стане для них більшим
ударом, ніж для гравців «Фрайбурга».
Звісно, життя не зупиниться, якщо ми програємо.
Тож хто отримає свій перший чемпіонський титул?
Обидва клуби мають великі фан-бази, які,
безсумнівно, підтримають їх в цю суботу,
Олімпійський стадіон цьогоріч буде
знову заповненим ущент.
Вже давно розкуплені квитки і
на стадіоні імені Фріца Вальтера в Кайзерслаутерні.
Дарма що перший матч
між «Кайзрслаутерном» та «Динамо Дрезден»
за місце в другій лізі минув без голів.
«Кайзрслаутерн», з гравцями в червоній формі,
мав кілька хороших моментів,
наприклад, спроба Бойда на 27-й хвилині,
яка, втім, виявилася безрезультатною.
Дрезденське «Динамо» здійснило непогану
спробу на 56-й хвилині,
однак Рааб швидко відреагував на Дафернера.
Хто ж все ж потрапить до другої ліги -
дізнаємося вже в цей вівторок у Дрездені.
Німеччина достроково проходить до чвертьфіналу
на чемпіонаті світу з хокею.
Оскільки  Данія сьогодні перемогла Францію,
команді Тоні Содергольма гарантовано місце в топ-8.
Хороші новини також і від наших тенісистів.
Анджелік Кербер завоювала свій перший за 6 років
титул на чемпіонаті світу з тенісу в Страсбурзі.
У фіналі вона перемогла словенку Кайю Юван,
відігравши понад 3 години, 3 тяжких сети.
А зараз поговоримо про кваліфікації до Формули-1.
Мік Шумахер вперше фінішував
десятим на гран-прі Іспанії.
Поул-позицію цьогоріч посів
Шарль Леклерк у Scuderia Ferrari.
Шарль Леклерк фінішував першим
на кожному тренуванні
та, як бачимо, повторив свій успіх
і у кваліфікаційному заїзді.
Це четверта поул-позиція для Леклерка в цьому сезоні.
Не в останню чергу через
проблеми Ферстаппена з його Red Bull.
На останньому кваліфікаційному етапі
стало очевидно, що шансів на перемогу
у Ферстаппена немає, однак почесне друге місце за ним.
Шумахер фінішував десятим.
Він вперше увійшов до третього сегмента кваліфікації.
Його конкурент Норріс прибув до фінішу раніше,
однак посів 11 місце через порушення правил.
Попри ультрасучасний автомобіль,
Себастьян Феттель посів аж 16-те місце.
Дякуємо, Катю!
З гонок у Барселоні відразу на
королівські американські гірки.
Королева Данії Марґрете II
катається на американських гірках,
погодьтесь, таке трапляється не щодня.
Її Величність було помічено сьогодні
у парку розваг Тіволі в Копенгагені.
Як бачимо, королева була в захваті від атракціону.
Це й не дивно, таким чином вона вирішила
відсвяткувати 50-ту річницю на престолі.
Королева на американських гірках -
оце так видовище.
Завтра погода буде здебільшого сонячною,
хоча в деяких регіонах можливі опади.
Детальніше за мить розповість Катя Хорнеффер.
Близько 22:45 Крістіан Зіверс
повернеться з черговою порцією новин,
цього разу в «heute journal».
Бажаю вам приємного та ненапруженого
вечора суботи. Побачимося завтра.
Добрий вечір.
Учора країною прокотилися сильні грози,
а в деяких регіонах навіть торнадо.
Фотографії з Падеборна облетіли весь Інтернет.
Циклон Еммелінде рухається на Схід,
звільнивши місце для Зевса.
Ці циклони з оригінальними назвами вже
в понеділок замінить інший - Фінья.
Сьогодні вночі на Балтійському морі дощитиме,
на півдні ж, навпаки, погода ясна, температура
знизиться до 12-5 градусів.
Завтра на нас чекає надзвичайно приємна погода.
Сонячно та хмарно водночас,
а отже - ніякої спеки.
В найгіршому випадку, на узбережжі Балтійського моря
та в районі Верхнього Рейну може дощити.
Парке повітря відійде з території Німеччини,
тож завтра температура коливатиметься
у межах комфортних 20-26 градусів, а на узбережжях
буде дещо прохолодніше - 16-18 градусів.
Потім настане понеділок і з ним
із південного заходу до нас знову завітають грози,
які знову матимуть штормовий потенціал.
Лише на північному сході погода не зміниться.
Вівторок видасться мінливим, а в середу настане
похолодання, температура впаде до 23-14 градусів.
Гарних вихідних!